hey it's me again
and we're gonna talk about eggs egg is
probably one of the healthiest things
you can eat if you eat the yolk most of
the nutrition is inside the yolk all the
fats are the vitamins all the essential
fatty acids you can consider the yolk
almost as if it's a multivitamin because
it's packed with lots of nutrition
there's very little nutrition in the egg
whites so always eat the whole egg
especially if you want to lower
cholesterol why because the antidote to
cholesterol is lecithin which is
contained in egg yolk
I've been eating about four eggs every
day for the last 20 years and my
cholesterol is pretty good so if you
ever want to lower your cholesterol you
want foods high in lecithin and that
would be the egg yolk so eat the whole
egg there's nothing wrong with eggs and
the problem when you buy eggs is that
they have these they're labeled as
hormone free or their antibiotic free
there they've been hormone free since
1949 so it's just a gimmick there it's
illegal to put hormones in the feed of
these chickens so that's one thing
number two when they say free-range that
doesn't mean anything it just means they
punched a couple holes in the barn to
let the chickens out for maybe a couple
of minutes but most the chickens never
even go out of the barn because they're
not allowed out until like the that
until they're quite a little bit older
so you want to buy eggs from farmers
farmers markets you don't want to buy
lot from large companies that you know
have farm farm raised chickens our farm
Factory chickens and the other point I
want to make is that some of the
chickens that are spiked with omega-3
fatty acids are spiked with fish oil
which gives that the egg fish taste so I
would recommend ones that are spiked
with flax oil alright so I just wanted
to make that point about these eggs and
make sure that you buy eggs from an
actual farmer or in the farmers market
or a high-end
egg at like Whole Foods where you will
you know it's a lot healthier than the
commercial at a like a typical giant
grocery store hope that helps